[Music]
yeah I just need it for a week while my
car's in the shop okay well in the
standard class I can get you Toyota
Corolla no offense but I don't think
that's gonna fly we're we're celebrities
yeah
cable celebrities okay I can upgrade you
to a roomier midsize car like a Chevy
Malibu okay and for five dollars more I
can upgrade you to the Batmobile does it
have a USB charger you know what it does
oh wait somebody left the CD in here huh
Bruce Wayne's hot jams give it a try
hold on
[Music]
I lost his parents violently and who
knows I have a good time
I would think it'd be a little more emo
yeah
voice modulator hello I love that I'm
playing with this and not even looking
at the road I'm Batman listening to my
own voice is more exciting than careful
driving I have no idea what I'm doing
right now buttons we haven't tried
cloaking device cloaking device give a
shot it's amazing we are 100% cloaked
all right Annie let's see what this baby
can really do all right thanks
Bravo officer yeah it's at 25 mile an
hour speed limit how fast was I going
438 miles an hour at the write your
ticket isn't there something I can do to
change your mind
little stomach mop you up well if I
could I'll bring you out into a summer
good what anger
hey can you guys just pull over let me
out can I get out can I get out oh
thanks a lot for this ice cream Andy hey
no problem
ah man it's getting real sticky I saw
some napkins in there I'll get them oh
yeah I think there's a pack of Wet Ones
back I think I turned on some kind of
countdown
did you get the insurance no I didn't
get the insurance insurance is a scam
you